[Music]
Leroy Smith had everything holy [ __ ] he
uses his cane this dude looks badass he
terrorized players online dude wink God
this characters so [ __ ] stood in the
road he crushed the prose offline no
other way for our tips in this oh and
for a few months Leroy destroyed tech
support good here we go right into the
Ranger that's gonna be the round you're
gonna leave me with the pixel leave me a
live thing you got a chance Leroy Smith
hasn't been around very long but he's
already one of the most infamous
characters in Tekken history for many
fans just hearing his name pisses them
off Leroy is dumb is Leroy going to be
your new main no I'm not trish player
but before Tekken fans were crying for
him to be nerfed into oblivion
they were drooling over him counting
down the days until his release
war black Jesus Leroy was first revealed
to the world at evo 2019 as one of the
new characters coming to Tekken 7 in
season past three
unlike Safina the character revealed
alongside him Leroy was brand new to
Tekken and many were calling him the
best original design the series had seen
any years I kind of loved the ID and the
look of Leroy as long as he he's
interesting enough you know an odd
overpowered or underpowered I think I'm
just gonna be super happy to have him
yeah but he they know about the
community community are up in arms about
him so I'm thinking are we gonna buff
him not like crazy before we at least
because everyone is so high and a few
months later at the Tekken World Tour
Finals Namco released a new trailer for
Leroy one that got fans even more
excited
[Music]
and you can't really blame people for
being hype I mean here oil looks cool as
hell he uses style how can you look at
this character and not immediately want
to play him and soon enough Tekken fans
got their hands on the Wing Chun master
but instead of a hype new character they
go to nasty surprise
his damage up for this two bigger ones
that natural can walk its name to become
buddy
and that's a combo explained dude white
duck went orbital right or orbital or
Perry those what white defense is
awesome right you want to go over yeah
it's gonna hurt unskilled great yeah and
it press this is all unskilled back to
regular
Tekken has had broken characters before
in fact the series in early years were
kind of a balanced nightmare you know
but over the years Tekken got more
balanced helped Tekken 7 was considered
by many to be the most balanced entry in
the series sure there were some obvious
top tiers but it really seemed like
anyone could win with any character no
one character truly dominated Tekken 7
until Leroy I think he's always going to
be a strong character by virtue of how
versatile he is but what they need to
try and folks do is not give him the
best version of every characters move
give him a slightly like a lesser
version and he makes up for it with his
versatility why was Leroy broken well
it's simple
he had everything insane damn it's great
combos pressure pokes and pretty much
every characters best move you name it
Leroy and unlike most broken Tekken
characters who came before him Leroy
didn't have a high execution barrier
pretty much anyone could pick him up and
start winning in a quest to make Leroy
the Tekken dream character Namco Bandai
made him a nightmare and I think it is
by far the largest balanced disaster
I've ever seen in any competitive video
game I've played in my life I haven't
played that many and I haven't been
fighting second for that long but I
essentially consider online second more
or less an unplayable game mode right
now and Leroy wasn't just broken at a
casual level even top players knew that
he wasn't busted what do you think I'm
Leroy so far
[Music]
broke Chicano Chicana on question
boutonnière OC Masuka mujahideen do I
make you eat a tomato come get
the New Kingdom what she's also
currently Killian and a oxen came in our
when he come if they don't change
anything about literally before evil
Japan's and I 100% sure 95% player all
players will play literally encourage me
Leroy came out just after the Tekken
World Tour Finals which meant he
couldn't completely destroy the
competitive scene as soon as he came out
but a few weeks later at Evo Japan Leroy
was tournament legal for basically the
first time and everyone finally got to
see just how broken he really was relax
- oh my gosh Lippert yo look that suit
when you think you could not shake for
you a sumo wrestler come on shout go for
the Orkney
duh
Evo Japan is a big deal it was the first
tournament of the year and had tons of
top players in attendance there's a lot
of prestige that comes with winning evo
Japan to the year before Arslan Ashe
came out of nowhere to win it all and
put Pakistan on the Tekken map but an
Evo Japan 2020 people weren't thinking
about if Arslan ash could defend his
title or even if the recently crowned
Tekken World Tour champion she couldn't
could keep up his solid performance no
an Evo Japan that year all eyes are on
only Roy you got to step it up a little
bit you guys play a cool we don't like
that here
no we're looking for Leroy's just Leroy
it's Leroy
so Leroy was busted that was not in
question but what people were wondering
is if the pros would abandon their manes
to pick up Leroy some Tekken players
have been rockin the same character for
years and while it seemed relatively
unlikely that they'd throw all that
practice away for a shot at winning with
a brand new character there was still a
chance I've been talking a few people
who are like street fighter copters
right huh I just they're they're giving
there they're like give me your thoughts
how many Leroy's are gonna be in this
top mate I don't think we're actually
gonna get that man I think that for some
reason or another Tekken players have
some kind of pride about their
characters that main and as soon as pool
started people realize that when they're
not the pros we're switching to Leroy he
was gonna be a pretty common sight any
bunch of man you did a block earlier
right yeah how was that what stuck over
here doing BB tag while you're here than
doing tech and so what what happened I
know Leroy right that's the man of the
hour right now yeah true I think I look
I go say he's he's too good but he's
definitely too good if you get like they
have fish you like whatever they're
accounting
why possible let's say that must have
been a mistake
I wasn't ready with a combo for them or
we're all big wimp but again you don't
want to try challenge that orbital he's
got it down to does he got his staff so
okay yeah he says he's gotta watch out
for the extension of it well I have
great fun
wall bounce to the reef flat knife is
done for the perfect and the big leak a
one amigo almost everyone was playing
Leroy if you weren't playing him at the
start of the tournament chances were you
switch to him before the end even some
of the best players in the world like
Chico Danann ulsan jump on the bandwagon
wing hunting their way to top eight many
fans in their hopes on players like
Arslan ash and knee who chose not to
play Leroy I actually have a feeling
that arson as can beat all the Leroy's
here alright so - can you bring it back
no siree he knows it he's gone away
four hearts it's in this terrible the
Rose was gonna do it he's in range
arsons of rage oh the back is dead why's
the match will not be repeating Leroy
there's the hand shapes to roam out of
all players - that is a shocker you
chuck I mean like I said one of the
worst I've seen by top eight seven out
of eight of the players left use Leroy
at some point in the tournament I want
to take a second and highlight just how
crazy that number is seven out of eight
it has been years since a fighting game
was so thoroughly dominated by one
character of the top level in 2018 when
Bayonetta broke smash more Evo still
only had three bayonetta's and top eight
in 2011 while young was dominating
Street Fighter 4 Arcade Edition there
were only two Young's in top eight in
just last year there were only three kit
ago coos and Evo's Dragonball Fighters
top eight and he was the single best
character in the game so the fact that
there were seven Leroy's and top eight
should be proof enough that he was
broken but get in it disco guys dick
with three more rounds if he can get
there if he got to get this round and
get three more to fall around
oh wee babe Mikio a fresh-faced julia
player who's the only person on top
eight who resisted the urge he beat down
dozens of to make his way to Grand
Finals going crazy right now it's so
close Oh Evo Japan but in the end to me
oh my god 50 50 times a nice page from
book to get up off the ground falling
this up the game is blocked the sweet
are we gonna get another one that will
be coming look running it all the way
through winners with other things he
wants with the boot character ad it fits
easy pull talons book takes it over big
deal what a value triangle and during
the award ceremony Evo Japan's newest
champion summarize the new tekken meta
perfectly yesterday I saw many comment
about the character I think a lot about
that in band final no final oh but yeah
just picked me
I think book is an extraordinary player
a true grinder who deserves a big win
like this he's a beloved figure in the
Tekken community but his win was
overshadowed by Leroy the day after Evo
Japan patched
3.20 was released with minimal Leroy
nerves and obviously Leroy will remain a
problem for the foreseeable future
because certainly some good nurse here I
like it
but he's still you know unbelievably
strong couple weeks later there was a
new patch except this one only had Leroy
nurse and a few months later
Leroy got hit with another set of nurse
I think the significant downgrade is
Leroy right and Leroy definitely got
that Dow Grady was in the top position
people come in yeah he's just steadily
dropping down he's not a struggling
character that's for sure he's still
decent but he's still held Leroy is
finally looking mortal don't get me
wrong he's still super good but he is
not the triple-s tier world leader that
could dunk on any character in the game
anymore at topanga's recent offline
Tekken League only one player made top
six playing Leroy and he ended up
finishing 6th but despite being more
balanced than before just hearing
Leroy's name is enough to
some people off yeah the other thing
with Leroy that I don't like is that he
was posted as dope as character it's
honestly their best design for a Tekken
7 character in my opinion everybody else
in Tekken 7 is kind of in whatever right
or gasps characters which are dope but
in terms of a original Tekken 7
character I felt this is Oh Leroy was
the coolest one but he's kind of got
this tarnished and tainted reputation
because he came out so loopy Leroy was
supposed to be the great Tekken hero
instead he was the villain terrorizing
everyone he was a single player boss
character who somehow made it a
competitive play and for a few months
he really really did ruin Tekken how do
you feel about this very bright light
how do you feel about me having to stand
in front of it for like 30 minutes
well it's not hot no I'm okay thank you
no I appreciate it usually have the
interns do that you know